(slow paced bubbly music)
- This is tube food.
We call it tube food because it is food
that is packed in a tube.
- [Narrator] U2 pilots in the air force
are a lot like astronauts.
They fly as hight as 72,000 feet,
and there's no oxygen.
So they wear pressurized
suits and helmets to breathe.
The only way to eat is
to slurp through a straw.
- What we do here is we make and design
rations for the U.S. military.
We are the only people
in the world who make it,
and these are tube foods.
We have approximately
19 different varieties
that we make here.
Apple pie, key lime pie, beef stew,
truffle mac and cheese.
(slow paced bubbly music)
The products used to be very puréed.
It looked a lot like baby food.
In fact, many of the pilots used to think
that Gerber manufactured
the tube-foods for them,
but about five years ago
the pilots came up to us
and they wanted something
that had texture,
more like regular food.
If you have a beef stew,
they wanted to be able to taste the peas,
and the carrots, and the meat,
and the potatoes separately,
not just as one mashed up product.
- [Narrator] So Dan and
his team of food scientists
in this lab set to work.
- [Dan] We try to grind
things up so that they do have
a particle size that's small
enough to fit through this tube,
yet still gives the
texture that the person
would normally have.
- [Narrator] Those tube-food flavors
aren't the only thing they've
developed in this lab.
From powdered cheese to instant coffee,
they've invented a number of products
that eventually made their
way into civilian life.
So is tube food our future?
- There hasn't been an
effective use of these products
in this country outside of the U2,
but we can see where it
might be useful for students
in a dormitory, campers,
anyone who wants to have
an easy eat on the go item.